today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
what's the future of the american right
wing
in the united states i know we have an
election coming up
where donald trump may get another four
years he may not get
another four years and certainly that's
going to be a big
part of setting the direction of the
republican party in the united states
for the next few years but my question
is actually more about the future
of the conservative movement or the
american right wing much of which is not
actually conservative which is part of
the discussion we have to have
and the future of the american right
could be through the republican party
or it might not and that's another part
of what i've been thinking about a lot
and
i've said before this part is not new
we're not breaking new ground here
trumpism isn't going to go away when
donald trump leaves the white house that
could be this january it could be
january of 2025.
there's actually a part of the american
right
that wants to get away from trumpism as
quickly as possible and
can't see the day when they finally get
away from trumpism
but you actually right now have an
american right wing
that is more divided than it's been in a
long time
certainly if you compare it to the era
of george w bush
even if you compare it to the era of
when john mccain and mitt romney were
respectively running against
barack obama in 2008 and 2012 the
american right is so divided right now
actually that many republicans aren't
even going to vote
for the incumbent republican president
this time around you've got we just
learned today prominent conservative
george will
has announced he sees trump as so
antithetical
to the republican party's values as he
sees them that he is actually going to
vote for joe biden
in november you have groups like the
lincoln project made up of well-known
republicans who are actively campaigning
against donald trump under the guise of
needing a return to sanity even though
we all intuitively know
as soon as joe biden gets elected if he
does
those republicans instantly go back to
being in the opposition i have no
confusion about
that whatsoever and there are actually
some real questions
about what is the direction that the
american right
wants to go in once donald trump
does leave office now on an issues level
we do see the country moving to the left
if you look at issues like abortion
being legal in most cases
that is more support today than it ever
has since roe v wade
if you look at support of gay marriage
you know other issues like
employers not being able to fire people
on the basis of sexual orientation
more than ever today the country is as
left as it has been on those issues
the country is as least religious as it
has been
since that's something that has been
tracked and the country
understands and trusts in science more
today
than it ever has in the balance with
religion the people who are on the
opposing side are very loud
and many of them are very loudly in
favor of donald trump so that can skew
the feeling
but that is a reality however
even though on abortion and gay marriage
and other issues the country
is more to the left than it has ever
ever been we do have a very divided
country needless to say
it's just a country that's divided um
along different lines
think about 2010 in response to
barack obama winning in 2008 the tea
party movement
surged in 2010 and the tea party
movement
became prominent it was a movement which
focused on
one particular conservative ideology the
sort of reactionary
don't tread on me stuff which includes
so-called liberty like deregulation and
lower taxes for the rich and it happened
to have some really wacky people in it
people in the tea party who were very
much in contrast
to the more establishment traditional
republicans of the time
mitt romney compared to the tea party
crowd
is not a trivial contrast even though in
2012 2010
they were basically all just voting for
republicans
when some tea party candidates were
elected in the 2010 midterms to the
house of representatives i suggested one
of two things is eventually going to
happen with this movement either
that is just a blip in terms of those
tea party views and they're going to be
pushed back
out and they'll be gone from the
republican party or
they'll become integrated into the
republican party and no longer be much
of a
separate group and that's essentially
what happened you do have a tea party
caucus in the house of representatives
it's not very prominent they have 23
seats in the house
modest but not insignificant and some
sort of more libertarian don't tread on
me ideas have infiltrated
the republican party big picture but
it's not dramatically
changed the republican party whenever
trump ultimately leaves
the american right is going to have to
make a decision about the direction they
want to go
the decision is not likely to be made by
some kind of central meeting
it's more likely a decision that's going
to be made implicitly by
who they vote for to be their nominee in
2024
who they vote for in the house who they
vote for in the senate
so some of the questions that come up
are
as an example is there a future in the
republican party
that bridges the sort of mitt romney
pro-business right
the religious right and the liberty
freedom right which
are the three groups that i've
identified previously
with what i am calling the fourth wing
of the right
which is the i i don't want to be
pejorative but it's like the reactionary
anti-intellectuals it's trumpism
essentially and
i don't really know what it should be
called this fourth group
it's a group that doesn't really care
about policy you've noticed that under
trump
it's not a particularly religious group
at least not by definition
but they basically see trump as a a
genius
and they favor doing things that just
trigger the libs
it's not about getting things done it's
not even about policy it's about being
reactionary
and inflammatory and using coarse
language and triggering the libs owning
the libs
is that going to be the direction of the
party
or is that fourth wing going to be
pushed into obscurity
and the future of the mainstream
american right
will remain in the republican party much
like
the left over the last four to six years
has become more about
you know there's been a coalescing of
sorts health care for everybody
dealing with inequality dealing with
climate are we going to see the right
shift in priorities if the future of the
right
is not through the republican party
where is it
and what does the republican party
become if the future of the american
right
is in the republican party what do they
do about trumpism
because i don't see trumpism becoming
enmeshed in the republican party in the
same way that the tea party
did these are important matters and i
want to hear from you about it and what
i care
most about really is we want to
understand this why it's not just an
academic exercise we want to understand
the future of the american right
so that the left can take advantage of
it we want
the chaos on the right whether the chaos
it starts in january with the
inauguration of joe biden
maybe it doesn't start until later down
the line how can the left
take advantage of the division on the
right and the uncertainty of the
conservative movement within or outside
of the republican party
to get things done that's the priority
it's an interesting academic and
philosophical exercise
but the goal of it is to figure out what
is our strategy for actually getting
things done
which includes by the way as part of the
american left pushing the democratic
party
to be more left than it actually is
we'll continue thinking about it and i
want to hear from you
at this point anybody who knows
this show well knows that i try
not to be hyperbolic or exaggerated when
i say
this is a concern that's something we
have to worry about
early in the coronavirus pandemic i got
emails from some of you who said david
you're being hyperbolic about the risk
of coronavirus
and it turned out that if anything i was
understating the risk that coronavirus
represented
now i want to be crystal clear with you
today the authoritarian
paramilitary deployment to portland
oregon
could well be just the beginning a test
case a trial balloon
for what is going to be a massive
authoritarian expansion over the next
several weeks
leading up to the november election
earlier this week donald trump said
he would continue to send federal law
enforcement to more american cities
including
the unmarked cars and the unidentified
forces and trump actually mentioned new
york chicago philly
detroit baltimore oakland as examples of
so-called as he calls it
liberal democrat cities where he would
be
interested in sending troops now
understand that this is happening
directly counter to the requests of many
of the state and local leaders so for
example
the mayor of portland oregon ted wheeler
does not want the troops there
they are there anyway when acting
secretary of homeland security
chad wolfe was recently interviewed
about this
he was asked about the fact that many
mayors and governors don't want these
troops there
he said it doesn't matter let's take a
look at the clip eight hours are just
misinformed uh they're not accurate
uh they don't understand the authorities
and the responsibility the department of
homeland security has we protect over
nine
almost nine thousand federal facilities
across the country we did that ten years
ago we did it long before this civil
unrest started and we'll continue
to do that and so i don't need
invitations by the state
uh state mayors or state governors to do
our job we're going to do that
whether they like us there or not that's
our responsibility
so of course the hypocrisy is astounding
in that the same people who talk about
states rights and local rights
are now saying we don't care that uh
if the federal government wants to be
there and the governors or the mayors
don't we're going to do it anyway
so then donald trump's press secretary
kelly mcinanny was asked about this
yesterday
and she actually cited a specific
statute and essentially defended this
action by saying
the federal government has property in
these cities and states and the federal
government is allowed to send troops to
protect that
property here she is yesterday and my
second question is where
in the constitution does the president
derive
the authority to send federal law
enforcement officers to the streets of
american cities
against the will of the elected
officials
in those cities yes well what you're
referring to is portland and 40 u.s
code 1315 gives dhs the ability to
deputize officers in any department or
agency
like ice custom and border patrol and
secret service quote as officers and
agents they can be deputized for the
duty
of uh in connection with the protection
of property owned or occupied by the
federal government and persons on that
property and when a federal courthouse
is being
lit on fire commercial fireworks being
shot at it being shot at the officers
i think that that falls pretty well
within uh the limits of 40 u.s code
1315.
that's a matter of protecting federal
property like federal courthouse in the
case of portland
does he see limitations to that power
how how much
how far does that power extend into the
into the streets of the city of portland
how
you know what are their limitations on
that so
that authority to protect a federal
property under the law we believe that
agents can conduct investigations of
crimes committed against federal
property or federal officers and in the
case where you have someone shooting off
a commercial grade firework
and then running across the street we
don't believe that that extends past our
jurisdiction
so there's two parts here to discuss the
first
is she mentions 40 u.s code 1315. that's
called
the law enforcement authority of
secretary of homeland security
for protection of property the next part
is
are they merely protecting property so
what the law
says is indeed that officers and agents
of dhs
can be deployed in connection with
protecting property that the federal
government owns or occupies so there
might be a property
that is not federal government property
but like a federal government
office or agency is based there so those
would be the two scenarios
property owned or occupied by the
federal government
there are two really important
limitations here though one is a
provision about authority
outside federal property where actually
it says
for the protection of property owner
occupied by the
owned or occupied by the federal
government the secretary
may enter into agreements with federal
agencies
and state and local governments to
obtain
authority for officers and agents
to enforce laws concurrently
with other federal law enforcement
officers and state and local law
enforcement
the secretary may do that if state and
local authorities want
but states don't want that in the case
of portland and in oregon
and in fact that's the next part that's
at issue here which is that kaylee
mcinanni is arguing
if they have to chase someone if someone
attacks a federal building and then
the troops have to chase that person
across the street across the street
she believes it is the opinion that she
says the government has
they are still within their jurisdiction
but the reality
from the widespread reports on the
ground and the videos that we're seeing
are that things are happening not just
across the street
but even blocks from so-called federal
property so the framing they've set up
is hanging by a thread it only hangs
together if you blindly accept it but
the truth is
the law allows federal troops to be
there concurrent with state and local
law enforcement
and they may make an agreement but the
local law enforcement does not have to
make that agreement
and they are going very fast and loose
when it comes to the definition of
federal property and that gets us to the
point of all of this
during yesterday's press briefing kaylee
mcinanni framed this
all as violent actors are are up against
law enforcement and trump is on the
correct side
trump is going to send people in he's
going to defend us it's all going to be
great
and she continued criticizing violence
of the protesters
it's really important to understand a
few things here number one
the violent incidents have increased
since the troops went in now
whether they're deliberately instigating
the troops
or their mere presence is aggravating
the situation we can debate that i'm not
taking a position on that
yet but the whole point of this is
number one
this is a gambit that the more violence
there is on tv
the more the country will turn against
protesters and
vis-a-vis that against or rather in
favor of donald trump
the second piece of it is that this is
all a test case in portland for
deploying the troops more broadly
trump has already given us a list of
cities but the deployment may happen
up to and including through election day
in order to intimidate people this is
not a trivial matter this comes down to
some of the fundamental
issues of state versus federal rights
the role of law enforcement
due process jurisdiction and in the end
it's a desperate cornered president
trying to get himself reelected
fighting for his political life with any
idea that occurs to him he has restarted
the coronavirus press briefings we
covered it yesterday live
he's sending in federal troops he's
tweeting attacks at people
he's holding press conferences where he
just reads attacks on joe biden off of a
piece of paper
he's claiming he's aced cognitive tests
that joe biden and chris wallace
wouldn't be able to ace
so at this point this is a cornered
individual
desperate for survival and on the show
yesterday as i said
a dangerous trump uh a rather
a desperate trump is a dangerous trump
and we should all be horrified by the
potential of this
if they get away with this in portland
it's proof of concept
that they can get away with
authoritarian crackdowns in other cities
and authoritarian crackdowns that will
last a while meaning
they will do more this is a test case
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at deepakman and make sure
you're signed up for free to the daily
audio podcast
yesterday again three weeks in a row
i've said this on wednesdays
yesterday was the best day ever
for the audio podcast incredible the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are elvis
harvey and jane
perkins elvis and jane thank you for
your support membership is
quick easy and cheap at joinpacman.com
and today's long time sustainer of the
day is ross greenlat ross has been a
member for almost
five years grab a membership don't be
shy at joinedpakman.com
i want to um start this next segment
with a reminder or or sort of a notice i
guess and i don't know that people are
necessarily thinking in these terms
the election is about to get going
voting starts in six weeks the first
absentee ballots are going to be going
out in north carolina on september 4th
in pennsylvania they go out on september
14th in michigan they go out on
september 19th
and this is incredibly important for a
few reasons number one
trump doesn't really have three and a
half months to to fix
something or to have some big win to get
voters back
for many voters he has six weeks and
when you look at those three states that
will
most soon be voting biden is up ahead
is up by two in north carolina up by
seven in pennsylvania and up by seven in
michigan those are averages of recent
pollings according to real clear
politics
this means that the election is
essentially now
trump has six weeks to turn around the
polls in those states
because as people start voting in
september and october that leaves fewer
people whose minds can be
changed in the second half of october
and in the last days before the election
so
the closing argument of the campaign as
it were need to start
happening very very soon in 2016 47
million people voted before election day
either with in-person early voting or
vote by mail absentee
the assumption this year because of
coronavirus is that
there will be dramatically more than 47
million people voting
either early or by mail especially by
mail i sent in my absentee ballot
request form
yesterday so this means a few different
things
number one the vigilance about voter
suppression
has to be escalated dramatically now
i've made an effort
since last election not to do the thing
where i start talking about voter
suppression october 5th
right of the year of the election we've
been talking about voter suppression
for years at this point we've been
covering the voter purges we've been
covering the opposition to vote by mail
we've been talking about voting machines
and all of it
so it should already be up but we need
to even talk more
about that and i'm going to talk more
about that on friday we would expect
that the president will become even more
erratic sooner than later
but really we now need to realize what
it is that we're doing
here you know people talk about the most
important election of my life
i believe this is the most important
election i will be voting in
so you know we talked a little bit about
this on the bonus show before
think about the 2012 election barack
obama had been president for four years
significant recovery uh from the great
recession
of 2008 economic expectations were
positive and you can find clips of me
saying
in october of 20 2012 i'm voting for
obama over mitt romney
but the reality is that if romney wins
we're probably going to have a good
economy for the for the next four years
all indicators were that the traditional
economic signals were pretty solid
that the economic policy of mitt romney
would certainly
tweak the trajectory a little bit but
romney had a different tax policy idea
romney had a different health policy
idea but generally speaking
whoever won in 2012 was going to preside
over four
relatively good years in the economy by
all of the standard
measures this is a very different
situation than what we have today
uh and so it wasn't that the 2012
election wasn't
important but even at the time not just
in retrospect
i remember having the recognition and
it's on record in video clips you can go
and fact check me
that this was not the most important
election i was participating in we now
are in a situation where we will either
have
four years of damage done by a
reactionary ignorant buffoon
or we are going to have eight years of
an even
more compromised more unhinged trump
in the latter four of those eight years
we
are sort of on the precipice of either
diving even deeper into the deep end of
ignorance and narcissism
or we can start to get the house in
order
we can start to regain respect from our
traditional allies
we can start to get away from being the
laughing stock that we have become
we can resume dealing with the climate
crisis we've gone the opposite direction
on climate
uh unfortunately joe biden has adopted
elements from the green new deal and
from bernie sanders
climate platform so is it perfect no but
we we you know you know this analogy or
this this example of
if a boat leaves new york uh across the
atlantic ocean
what after 10 miles is only a difference
of a few hundred yards in terms of the
angle
can end up with you in in europe or
africa
uh as you cross the atlantic ocean so
that's the importance of starting to
right the ship today
we hopefully would be seeing an increase
rather than a decrease in the number of
people with health insurance if joe
biden were to win
in november we could stop worrying that
if a supreme court justice were to get
sick or die or retire
it would plague us with decades more of
the conservative nonsense that we've
been seeing
so these are not trivial matters and i
know it
feels like a way off november it's more
than three months for some voters it
starts in six weeks
for many voters the decision about who
they're going to vote for
is going to be made in the next four to
five weeks and they will vote
in six weeks so time is flying right now
for a lot of us
the days look quite similar those of us
who are still socially distancing
four months in quarantine each day felt
long
but the four months have just flown by
six weeks
are going to fly by the next three
months are going to fly by and if i
don't
um feel that i've done everything i can
to stop this insanity
i would not be able to live with myself
so it is now election time we've got
the conventions coming up in whatever
form they take place
we have potentially debates coming up
and voting starts
in six weeks the opportunity will be
there
for october surprises and then that's it
i mean this thing is almost over
are we going to have four more years of
utter depravity or can we remove this
lunacy from the oval office and start to
it's just the start it's just
turning the ship can we start to
reintroduce sanity uh to
our federal leadership and of course one
of the biggest issues to consider
is coronavirus and that's what i want to
talk about a little bit next
the coronavirus pandemic although
very much under control in much of the
world i have friends uh
touring belgium france a lot of
different countries things are you know
everybody's wearing
masks on public transit but it's a very
normal life
it is not under control here in the
united states in fact it's spiraling
completely out of control dr anthony
fauci said
about a month ago we could be heading
towards hundred thousand new cases per
day
sounded according to some hyperbolic at
the time doesn't seem like it
and what were originally only spiking
cases
are now starting to be spikes in
hospitalizations
and spikes in deaths and in fact
yesterday july 21st
we had the most deaths in a day
dating all the way back to the second of
june okay
50 days the highest death toll in
50 days yesterday tragically
hospitalizations have re-surged to
essentially
the highest point we've had we're close
to the hospitalization peak of mid-april
of course we have this lag time where
first you see cases
then you see hospitalizations then you
see deaths
and that is exactly what we are seeing
there were some people saying
the death surge isn't going to come most
deaths
in 50 days 51 days yesterday so
we're in a race against time here we're
in a race against time when it comes to
a treatment and a vaccine
we're in a race against time when it
comes to removing donald trump and
putting someone there who will just say
doctors need to deal with this not
politicians
but because we've failed to deal with
this
we have much less time than other
countries do hospitals are filling back
up
deaths are creeping up icus in florida
texas other hot spots are anecdotally
reporting
being at capacity or close to capacity
our ability to maintain
a lower mortality rate depends on
keeping icus
open with space available hospitals with
space available
many states have that and that's great
many states tragically do not
and the top hot spots continue to be
california texas florida arizona
georgia's now a bigger and bigger piece
of the problem tennessee
the growth rate in idaho is very very
high even though the case numbers
themselves are not yet that high
um the carolinas oklahoma and louisiana
missouri uh mississippi alabama i mean
it's a
it's bad in a lot of the country and
when we look at this not state by state
but by county
um looking at the map that we have up on
the screen for our video audience we see
that there are these large swaths where
things
are under control at the county level
and those are mostly in the northeast
and then in the
the mountain time zone area but then a
ton of orange and red colored counties
on the map
where um cases are not under control
and are getting worse there's a term i
don't know that this is really a term i
i i'm not saying i created this but i've
been using it i haven't heard other
people use it
it's sort of virus escape velocity
escape velocity the idea
of uh the force required to escape
the gravitational pull of the earth for
um a
craft that is trying to exit earth's
gravitational pull
we are very close to getting to virus
escape velocity and escape velocity when
applied to the
virus would be the point at which the
cases are growing so quickly
that even if you immediately shut
everything down like
a full block people don't you know i'm
talking like an authoritarian lockdown
even there you would continue to see a
dramatic spike because there's just so
much so much virus out there and
incubating if we aren't already there in
some of these states that are hot spots
we are very close and the situation by
august 15th could be
unconscionable is the word i would apply
to it now this is optional i really want
people to remember that
italy was hit early as a hot spot but is
completely under control right now and
life is returning very much to normal
there switzerland was hit later for
people who say well if you were hit
earlier you're under control but the u.s
was hit later
switzerland was hit later than italy
they are also completely under control
so at this point this has been going on
long enough five months five plus months
the first cases we know were actually in
late december in the us but
you know in a serious way we're talking
about five months this is no longer
about getting hit earlier or getting hit
later
it's now policy it takes about 10 weeks
to flatten and attack the curve if you
do it right
we're five months in every country now
has had the chance
many have done it we are every day
building
the pandemic people are desperate to get
back to normal so am i
well everybody's got to put a mask on
you've got to stop the indoor events
you've actually got to do the work
required to do it and i'm horrified
horrified
by where we might be in 20 days i hope
i'm wrong
so far unfortunately if anything i've
been
i've been too optimistic in other words
i was thinking you know by june 1 june
15
we're going to have very few cases
that's the way the models are looking
well
we just it was a disaster people didn't
do what we were supposed to do
we didn't have that lull and we may be
heading full speed ahead
into an even bigger it's not even a
second wave just an
even bigger continuation directly into
the fall
and flu season so we'll be polling our
audience on our instagram page which is
david pakman show about
what you're doing and what you expect in
the fall so make sure you're following
us there
and we will be back with much more right
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today david shimer who's a fellow at
yale university and also
author of the book rigged america russia
and 100 years of covert
electoral interference david the title
already tells us
a lot about uh my my first question but
um in the in the discussion about
alleged russian interference in the 2016
election
and planned interference in 2020 there's
this bigger discussion
of how long has transnational election
interference been going on so so maybe
let's start there where
how long has it been going on sure so
what i do in my book is i restore
history to the subject of covert
electoral
interference because a myth that is
prevalent in our discourse today
is that russian interference in the 2016
election
um was somehow new or novel or
unprecedented
and and that's dangerous because if
something's treated as unprecedented
then it's treated as something that
there's no history behind and it's very
easy to manipulate how people perceive
it and whether people even believe it
happened
and what i do in this book is show that
in fact for the last century beginning
in 1919
the soviet union for a period the united
states and then now putin's russia have
been interfering in elections all over
the world i show where
i show why i show how they have used
their intelligence services
to direct and disrupt open elections
and i then use that history to shine new
light on what actually happened in 2016
how we can understand what putin
achieved and what we should be doing now
to defend our elections both before
november
and and thereafter so there's like five
different
branches that we could explore i'll just
pick one to start with
what would be since 1919 the most
successful
examples of that interference sure so
there's one case that that it was
actually what sparked my interest in
this whole subject
which was in 1972 there was a vote of no
confidence in the
chancellor of west germany willie brandt
and this and this vote of no confidence
came
at a pivotal moment in the history of
the cold war willie brandt had been
executing a foreign policy of us politic
he had been reestablishing relations
with the soviet union with the eastern
bloc
a real pivotal cold war figure which um
as a result of his groundbreaking
policies sparked
dissent within his parliamentary
coalition and there was a vote to remove
him from office as chancellor
that vote failed by two votes just two
after which he was able to ratify the
treaties he'd been pursuing and
and really pursue um to completion um or
as he saw
his foreign policy and what i reveal in
the book is that
there was a covert operation executed by
east german intelligence ordered by
moscow
to purchase those two votes and i
interviewed one of the intelligence
officers
who participated in that operation he
now lives just outside of berlin i spent
about half a day with him
i went through a bunch of different
archives and recreated this story
and it's a story of targeting two
vulnerable lawmakers
who were very corruptable because of
their womanizing their debts um their
alcoholism
turning them drawing them in slowly and
then paying them each 50 000 deutsche
marks in exchange for their extensions
and then covering it up and it took
decades for this operation to come out
um and had the east german intelligence
agency not interfered in this vote the
outcome would have been different brant
would have fallen from power and the
trajectory of the cold war would have
changed
um and it did not as a direct result of
covert interference
just briefly do you know offhand how
much 50 000 deutsche marks then is
roughly
like how many dollars today would we be
thinking about like a little less than a
hundred thousand dollars
okay so it's not a crazy amount no
certainly given the
the the way in which it redirected the
the trajectory of things at the time
um now as a sort of disclaimer moment
you we are not arguing here that russia
is the only country that does this we
are just we happen to be talking about
russia but that's a common defense that
number one other countries also do this
and number two the u.s
also does this elsewhere you're not
denying either of those assertions
no i'm denying i'm denying neither of
those assertions but i do make the
argument in my book
that the story of covert electoral
interference is primarily to this point
this may change now moving forward but
to this point has primarily been a story
of
moscow and washington so between 1919
and 1947
the soviet union was interfering in
elections all over the world with brief
interruptions and very intensely
between 45 and 47 across eastern europe
between 1948 and 1991
the cia and the kgb were going
toe-to-toe in elections all over the
world
in order to either seek to defeat or
advance
leftist candidates and since 1991
vladimir putin's regime has rediscovered
and enhanced the weapon of covert
electoral interference using the
internet
he is once again targeting elections all
over the world in order to support
authoritarian minded and divisive
candidates
and now one of the countries under
attack in a real meaningful way is
america itself
so this is a very old story and there
are many lessons to draw from that story
as we seek to understand our present
moment
it is not accurate to say that it is
just russia that has been executing
these sorts of operations but we also
shouldn't minimize the role of moscow in
this history because moscow really has
been the pioneer
um beginning with vladimir lenin in 1919
to the regime of vladimir putin today
so what was done in 2016
and i think maybe what would be useful
would be to contextualize it in
you know when you have an election that
ultimately comes down to about 75 000
votes in three states and otherwise
would have would have been a hillary
clinton
win uh we have to balance
what russia did with james comey
opting to do a second presser about
hillary clinton's emails
with targeted social media campaigns
hillary clinton
not going to wisconsin right like we can
when it's so close
it's hard to say one thing was the
difference maker but that still means we
should explore
what exactly did russia do exactly and i
think it's a real
trap to fall into the question of
effectiveness when it comes to
operations to manipulate people
because there are two ways to manipulate
an election to alter actual ballots and
to manipulate minds public opinion
and as i said i've scoured this history
i interviewed more than 130 people eight
former cia directors
gone through archives across six
countries and what comes out of that
history
is that for operations to manipulate
people there's
never a clear answer as to how many
people were manipulated or how many
people's minds were changed it's about
making informed analytical judgments and
then
orienting future policy based on those
judgments it's the first point the
second point as to what russia did
is russia did three things the first is
russia's systemically manipulated social
media platforms with with propaganda
in spreading propaganda that advanced
its two objectives to sow discord and
division
um and to advantage one candidate over
another which by the way is nothing new
i spent about half a day with the former
kgb general and they tried to do both of
those things
in many u.s elections during the cold
war they just didn't have social media
to do it
the the second thing that russia did was
hack and release sensitive emails that
were damaging to
hillary clinton's candidacy and the
third thing that russia did
was systemically target our voting
systems which was actually what
captivated the obama administration in
the summer and fall
because russian military intelligence
was scanning probing and penetrating
our election infrastructure to the point
where according to folks like john
brennan
russia had the ability to alter the vote
alleys and voter data of u.s citizens on
election day itself
so there's people who will look at that
and they'll say you know that's a lot of
work
for ultimately getting donald trump
elected
um to the extent that it helped and in
the end
donald trump really hasn't done that
much that seems great for russia
and you'll have people provide lists on
both sides here's things that trump did
that seem
good for russia here's things trump did
that seem not so good
for me it's never really been about that
it's been about
listen the the u.s now is a
laughingstock in a way that it was not
prior to 2016.
the u.s is not in conversations about
climate change because trump says
it's a hoax created by the chinese the
u.s is increasingly i mean on
coronavirus we're not leading
for me it's not about getting specific
concessions
it's about questioning how stable is the
u.s
and how how clearly are people thinking
and it's a bigger picture thing where
it's sort of the downfall
of american democracy broadly more than
about
trump doing things for putin is that the
right lens or is it a different lens we
should be thinking of
no you're spot on i think a real
misconception is that
putin got help to get trump elected so
therefore trump is going to
cede ukraine to russia or something like
that and and that kind of transactional
view of why trump is a value to putin
and that really misunderstands putin's
foreign policy and his and his and his
his strategy really which is in america
to degrade disrupt and discredit
american democracy to corrupt american
democracy in itself so when trump causes
chaos
when trump sews discord when trump
erodes democratic
norms that is the dream of russia the
the
that matters so much more than what
might be happening regarding a specific
foreign policy decision
because what vladimir putin wants is for
american democracy to erode
for him to therefore be able to say to
his own people see democracy doesn't
work
um the story of american democracy was a
myth
and you shouldn't want that it opens up
new opportunities for influence for him
because as america retreats as a leader
abroad
that means that states will therefore be
more
susceptible to russian influence
and it also makes it so that america is
so divided at home
is so disrupted at home that america
can't push back against russia abroad
and can't engage with russia
in a meaningful way abroad so trump
could do nothing
transactionally that helps russia and
yet the trump presidency can be of
enormous value
to putin and that is the best way to
understand what trump's presidency has
thus far been for example
what we see happening in portland right
now you know it's having
soldiers or dhs officials who don't have
marks on their uniforms
it's reminiscent of what putin did in
ukraine with his soldiers being unmarked
and it also shows that america and
russia
you know it enables this what about this
sort of argument that that america
should be seeking to rebut
because there is no equivalency or
should not be between russian and
american behavior domestically
when it comes to the other superpower of
china
um one of the allegations that has been
made
is that donald trump specifically asked
the chinese president
for help when it comes to farmers the
idea being
china buys stuff from american farmers
this helped trump helps trump with the
farmers that helps him get reelected in
2020. that's like a really specific ask
more broadly there's this interview from
last year where trump was interviewed by
george stephanopoulos and stephanopoulos
said
if russia or china came to you with
information that was useful to you
would you call the fbi would you accept
it and trump said well yeah i would look
at it first and then you know maybe i
tell the fbi maybe i wouldn't
talk a little bit about either
abstractly or concretely
the role of china in the 2020 election
so i think that's a really open and
interesting question because 2016 was a
turning point in this history in a
couple of ways one of which
was it was the first time the issue of
covert electoral interference was really
broadcast to the world
it exited the shadows and it showed
china iran north korea whomever
you can really disrupt american
democracy with not that much money
um and with relatively simple ideas
because of how exposed our country is
so i think a question on my mind is
whether china seeks to
imitate and further the russian model or
whether this will continue to be a
russian tradition i don't know the
answer to that i think we will know the
answer in the coming months
but i think something that we should be
clear-eyed about is that to this point
this has been much more a russian story
than a chinese story
so folks who say china will break new
ground here or north korea or iran and
it's as if everyone's operating from the
same starting point that's just not
true you know vladimir putin worked for
the kgb for 15 years he was a part of an
agency that was interfering in elections
all over the world there's a history
here
there's a reason why russia is at the
forefront here and i think we should
keep that in mind and a brief point on
trump
i also think americans really need to
keep in mind that regardless of what he
says this is not a political
issue if you believe in this threat that
doesn't make you you know a democrat
the the soviets targeted ronald reagan
during the cold war a republican
they targeted richard nixon a republican
to destroy their campaigns
now they just so happen to be helping a
republican but the point isn't to help a
republican the point is to further the
interests of the russian state
which is to degrade corrupt and tear
down american democracy
and that is not in alignment with the
interests of any american citizen
regardless of political party
so to touch on 2020 and russia then
if you look at the polls now they
certainly don't look good
for donald trump but as i've been
telling my audience
you have to assume nothing you have to
vote as if your vote is the deciding
vote in your state that's really the
only the only intelligent way forward
but does does russia's ability to meddle
become diminished if indeed the election
is not close
or do their priorities change or how
does that affect things
so their priorities change because
another myth here is that russian
interference is just about getting
donald trump elected
again not true russia's operation to
interfere in the 2016 election
started in 2014 before trump even
announced his candidacy
and as i reveal in my book based on my
interviews with john brennan and jim
clapper
russia had plans to continue interfering
in our politics to undermine hillary
clinton had she
won the election and they were basically
starting that operation
before trump even won which surprised
putin so as we await
election day now it's important to keep
in mind that the foremost russian
objective again
is to undermine our democracy to sow
doubt about the functioning of our
democracy and yes
trump might be losing but new
opportunities emerge such
as if donald trump is alleging that the
election will be rigged
it is in russia's interest for americans
to believe their election is rigged
because that makes americans no longer
believe in their democracy so russia
could and this is hypothetical
but russia did have this capability four
years ago you know scramble voter
registration databases cause
chaos at polling places anonymously to
therefore provide fodder to those who
would allege that the election was
rigged
for the democratic side so therefore
after the election half the country
might not actually believe in the
outcome of the election
which would only so further division and
further discredit american democracy in
the eyes of the world as well as its own
people so
there are many ways to achieve the
russian objective
donald trump is a means to an end of
that objective of undermining american
democracy but he's not the end in itself
and americans should keep that in mind
because this threat will not disappear
regardless of whether donald trump loses
because this is a long-running russian
mission
the kgb has targeted american elections
for decades russia
has been interfering in our politics
since before trump came on the scene and
that story will continue
in 2021 and beyond the book is
rigged america russia and 100 years of
covert electoral interference we've been
speaking with the books author david
shimer a fellow at yale university
i so appreciate your time today thank
you very much
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
here's a quick story just about another
one of these self-inflicted
embarrassments for the current
administration yesterday you actually
had two press events but both of which i
covered live
in the morning you had donald trump's
press secretary kaylee mckennany
do a standard press briefing where she
comes out speaks for like 90 seconds
75 seconds or usually or lies the other
15 are just saying hello
and then in the afternoon donald trump
did his own press briefing and what was
very
interesting was that in the morning the
topic of testing came up and the topic
of trump not wearing a mask
came up and weirdly when kaylee
mckennony was trying to defend trump
not wearing a mask in many situations
she said listen
trump's tested multiple times a day for
coronavirus
which is weird and um i'll play that
part of this for you first
donna kelly he hasn't warned him so it's
sending
is it not mixed signals the president
wore a mask in may the president wore a
mask at walter reed out of an abundance
of caution but as i've made clear from
this podium the president
is the most tested man in america um
he's tested more than anyone multiple
times a day
and we believe that he's acting
appropriately the president
is tested for coronavirus multiple times
per day that's definitely odd but okay
so then hours later you knew it was
going to happen donald trump was asked
earlier your press secretary said you're
tested multiple times per day for
coronavirus
can you talk about how frequently that's
happening and trump says he looks
clearly confused and he says
i can't even think of one time where i
was tested more than once in a day
usually i'm tested once every two or
three days what
yeah take a look mr president uh first i
just wanted to get a clarification your
press secretary said today that you
sometimes take more than one test a day
why is that
and how well i didn't know about more
than one i do take
probably on average a test every uh two
days three days and
i don't know of any time i've taken two
tests in one day but i could see that
happening
so this is once again not an issue of
interpretation
this is just a very concrete practical
matter kaylee mckennany defends
trump's lack of mask wearing by saying
he's getting tested
multiple times per day now if that were
true
that would raise questions of why are
most people waiting five to seven days
for results
and trump's getting multiple tests with
almost immediate results although
i get it he's the president but the
point is we
still have a testing problem in this
country if you don't get your results
back for five to seven days as many
people don't
you can spread the disease to multiple
people while you're waiting for your
test results
and trump is barely wearing a mask and
getting multiple
tests per day but then trump just
straight up says i don't know anything
about
multiple tests in a day i'm tested once
every two to three days so if there's a
briefing today i'm sure kaylee mckenna
will be asked about it
i'm sure she'll have some prepared
explanation that may already have
happened by the time you see this or
maybe there will be no press briefing at
all today but as usual
caught lying again and the theme is they
go
too far when there's by i i don't want
to say this is
this is a normal question everybody's
told to wear masks why isn't trump
wearing one
when they see a hostile question an
accusatory question as far as they are
concerned
they go overboard in trying to defend
and that's how you get this why isn't
trump wearing a mask oh he's tested all
the time he's tested multiple times a
day
and there's other examples of this when
trump says something racially off color
and then he's called on it
he'll say things like i am the least
racist person ever like oh hold on a sec
that's a weird thing to say
maybe just say you're not racist but the
least racist person
ever you know saying i'm not racist it
wouldn't be any more believable quite
frankly but it will it would at least be
more plausible or
when asked about testing trump says we
have the best
and the most testing well no we the best
not really
the most no not per capita uh
the fastest results certainly not when
asked about deaths trump says we have
the lowest
mortality rate well no we don't of
course none of these things are true
and it is another one of these little
self-inflicted cuts
that comes from trying to be hyperbolic
and go against
anything perceived i mean they're so
triggerable they're so thin
skinned that what would qualify as just
a basic obvious journalistic question in
any other country with a free press
here these are seen as attacks and they
actually generate
obvious and provable lies i want to do a
story about
this idea that an ounce of prevention is
really worth a pound of cure
there are some states that did not take
coronavirus seriously early on
and those states are the ones that now
are having
some of the largest outbreaks in the
world on a case growth rate basis
and some of them are being forced to now
go in the complete opposite direction
and adopt some of the even more
authoritarian
uh techniques or rules than we saw
in some of the early hot spots and we
talked earlier about
california florida arizona carolinas
tennessee louisiana mississippi you know
red states plus california basically but
i want to talk about texas
briefly right now texas hesitated to do
much
early on in the pandemic texas then
after sort of closing some stuff
they started reopening very quickly mass
use was not high in texas for
a very long time their republican
lieutenant governor dan patrick you
might remember went on tv and said i
would sacrifice myself and i know many
other grandparents would as well
to coronavirus to save the economy
but things have gotten so ugly so
quickly in texas
icu's very full hospital is very full
approaching what i'm calling virus
escape velocity in texas that
hidalgo county texas issued a threat
that a notice i guess i would call it
that if you test positive for the virus
and you break the mandatory 14-day
quarantine
you will be prosecuted criminally the
hidalgo county twitter account
tweeted this out making it clear do not
leave your house
do not have any visitors make a list of
people that you have been in contact
with
and you are subject to criminal
prosecution
if you don't comply with this now
there's a few things here of course to
think about
one is are they really going to
prosecute i don't know they're certainly
threatening to now of course a lot of
texas right-wingers
are saying things like this is the
gestapo
these are jack-booted government thugs
the truth is actually the opposite if a
place needs to do something like this
it's because people are not doing it
already in any common sensible world you
would never
need such a notice because obviously
anybody who test positive would not be
leaving their house they would be home
for 14 days
because they understand the risk of
continuing to spread the disease
the fact that this was published is a
signal
about how bad the situation is and
meanwhile if we zoom out from hidalgo
county to texas more broadly
the death curve is looking very very
ugly a very steep spike
in the seventh day moving average of
death numbers in texas
no sign that things are turning around
remember we have a progression which is
cases spike hospitalization spike
and then death spike early in the case
spike
in sort of like mid to late june there
were a lot of uh
deniers i would call them who were just
repeating
cases aren't going to lead to deaths
it's younger people getting it
we are better at treating it it's less
serious now you know all these different
comp pic pick your poison so to speak
and i was interested in that and i came
to you and i said
this may be true or it may just be the
20-day lag time
then we started to see hospitalizations
increase in texas we heard in houston
that a bunch of icus were getting full
we heard in austin the mayor of austin
was concerned about how full they were
getting
that was the sign that this may just be
a lag time it may be as we've seen cases
followed by hospitalizations followed by
deaths and case in point
that is what we are seeing right now now
the big hot spots in the u.s
again reminder it's basically california
and a bunch of red states
um dr fauci a couple of weeks ago said
we
could be heading towards 100 000 cases
per day
we've been sort of studying on weekdays
between 60 and 75 000 cases per day
i wouldn't be shocked if we do an 80 000
new case day
this week if things do not turn around
again
i know i'm doing this twice today but
it's so important i know we have a lot
of viewers in these in these
areas we're going to reach
virus escape velocity and by august 15th
it could make today look not that bad
and that's very very scary so
we haven't won this is not what winning
looks like do not be confused
uh not that many of you are but most of
you understand that we are not winning
and forget about august 15th what's the
fall going to look like
if we never flatten the curve remember
we were expecting
a total dip to almost no new cases
almost no new deaths by june 1st or june
15th
it never happened we had a slight
decline down to 20 000 cases a day
and then back up like a rocket what will
the fall
look like if this doesn't turn around i
have a voicemail number which you are
invited to call
any time of day whenever you get the
hankering just give me a call
219 to david p here's a voicemail i got
about 20 grand i've been waiting for
take a listen to this
hey david i remember um a few days ago
and it was last week you mentioned that
the creator of parlor
uh the conservative twitter clone
uh said that they would offer a bounty
of
i think was it twenty thousand dollars
yes
progressive with over fifty thousand
followers or indeed it was vice versa
but by the way you said you tried to
take him up on that and he still can
take you back and i'm wondering
uh has he ever resolved that no so
basically yeah parlor
you know republicans said our free
speech rights are being taken away on
twitter
so some guy created an app called parlor
and he said multiple times right around
the july 4th
long weekend holiday that if any
progressive with over 50 000 twitter
followers signs up they'll pay them a 20
000
bounty so i have 130 000 twitter
followers i signed up i tweeted to the
guy and i said i'm
ready for my 20 grand didn't say
anything next day i tweeted again
i did what you said i signed up i'm
ready for my 20 grand
still got nothing and ultimately i just
deleted the parlor account so in
addition to being
liars about the circumstances of
censorship on social media
also liars in terms of they said we'll
pay 20 grand if uh
you know i met the requirements and they
did not pay me you may not be surprised
by that
we are going to talk on the we've not
talked a lot on the bonus show about the
return of sports in the coronavirus era
there's actually some really interesting
things going on which i want to discuss
we're also going to talk about a black
woman facing prison for a voting mistake
and prosecutors just doubled the charges
against her and donald trump has ordered
undocumented immigrants
excluded from a very important census
count remember
it's 2020 the census is going on in the
midst of everything else that's
happening
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show remember you can get
instant i'm talking instant
instantaneous
speed of light access to the daily bonus
show
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
or
two options become a patron at
slash patreon.com pakman show we'll see
you on the bonus show or if not
tragically we won't see you until
tomorrow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video